this is the first time that shelly
anderson has been able to hug her mum
audrey it is a moment of contact that
they've craved for so long
earlier they met like this as they have
done since march
but a new test quick but not always
accurate
has changed all that your instinct with
anybody is to give them a hug especially
if they're upset or anything like that
and they're upset not seeing you not
seeing the rest of the family the
grandchildren the great grandchildren
but to just be able to give her that hug
in that close contact it'll just be
amazing
rapid tests known as lateral flow tests
were trialled in liverpool last month
but in two out of ten tests the results
showed negative when the person was
actually positive
despite that the department for health
say they're accurate
enough to be used in care homes but
there are still doubts
they are improving and always improving
at the moment those tests
should be administered uh usually
through somebody who's trained uh
the ultimate aim is to have them
available to use for self tests
and in sheffield public health directors
have told care homes
not to use them for now that's a nice
big smile like that beautiful smile
westbourne house residential nursing
home in the city
is covered free and they want to keep it
that way
authenticated have you heard anything
about rapid floor tests when you'll get
them
how you'll administer them whether you
need any training on them
we've got we've not got anything through
yet the only guidance we've had is not
to use them because
at the moment they're wanting further
clarification on how safe they are
so today we're expecting to be
delivering visits
getting families and their loved ones
back together hugging each other and
it's just not possible so
that's upsetting for everybody really
rapid tests
pose the ultimate dilemma relatives
want to see their loved ones they've
waited so many months to do it
and these tests could be critical to
that
but they have to be accurate otherwise
the consequences
could be fatal you're better not having
a test than having a test that you can't
be confident
rob lindley really wants to visit his
mum ellen here
but he's simply not sure would you take
the test
and if it came back negative would you
go in and hug your mum no no
not with the lack of confidence i have
in in
this particular test fantastic that
that's the way we're going that we've
got a fast
rapid test it's what we've needed all
the way along but i just don't have
confidence in it
care home providers have told sky news
that rapid tests might make care homes
safer
but they're unlikely they say to lead to
homes opening their doors again
not yet at least nick martin sky news
sheffield